hello believe nation in the start of a
new series we're calling the DG no
series our first video is gonna be on 9
surprising facts about Tony Robbins I
hope you enjoy fact number one he
started in the person development field
when he was working for Jim Rohn at the
age of 17 selling his motivational
seminars I was working for Jim Rohn this
speaker and I was 17 years old I had
long hair minestrone soup acne on my
face and I was trying to call on Bear
Stearns type of people and convince them
why they should go to this man seminar
be more successful I was driving a 1968
Volkswagen that I'd earned at $40 a week
as a janitor the only way I did it was
parked far from the building and then go
in and I love people I believe and I put
myself in state and I was able to
influence people that were far more
successful I was at the time I had a
dear dear friend and mentor named Jim
Rohn who was my teacher when I was 17
years old he's somebody I sent out some
videos I'll probably attach some things
to this video or another one about him
just to honor him and his teachings but
he gave me a way of looking at life that
allowed me to not ask life would be
easier but to ask that I be better
he got me to realize that the secret to
life was to work harder on myself than
my job or anything else because then I'd
have something to give people and he
really shaped me and he just passed away
and I was thinking wow I'm gonna be 49
years old I met him when I was 17 think
of the fact that my journey is just
beginning and think of all the impact of
just a couple ideas out of my life and I
want to really continue to do that for
you or anybody you care about so fact
number two what made his early career
was when he challenged a psychiatrist
saying that he could cure someone snake
phobia in a matter of minutes so I mean
it's the famous story about something I
forgot Nana it was if somebody had some
kind of phobic snake phobia that's I got
for seven years and you did it in 15
minutes yeah and but what made my career
was that I was attacked by the
psychiatrist on the radio saying you're
a liar you're a charlatan people like
you should not be allowed on the radio
you can't do this and so I was a real
rebel frankly I was like in his face
saying gray are you a scientist if you
are then test your hypothesis give me
your patient I'll be
the Holiday Inn tomorrow night so it was
like this shootout and it was like a
movie he brought her I wiped it out I
wrapped the snake around her a phobia is
an uncontrollable physical response to
some stimulus you know it's not just
fear it's shaking spitting and if the
Andrews don't they finally worked on it
for seven years so that became my
signature it was to challenge and then
gradually I grew because I was really
just trying to prove to everybody and
myself as well that I was worthy rather
than you know maturing a little bit and
just knowing that there are skill sets
that are valuable for everybody fact
number three in the 1980s he used
television infomercials to promote his
books and programs do you want to
establish good credit now you can thanks
to this exciting new program from Tony
Robbins hi I'm 20 Robbins I'm the author
of the National best-selling book
unlimited power for over ten years now
I've helped over a million people to
take control of their life mentally
emotionally physically and financially
and so many people I mean have pain in
the area of credit if you're one of the
40 million Americans it really needs a
Visa card we have a solution that's
guaranteed I could have the easiest most
affordable way to guarantee you a Visa
card immediately our program will also
show you how to take control of your own
financial freedom for your $2.99 for a
minute call you'll receive information
about how to get your very own Visa card
with no deposit required
you'll hear Tony Robbins seven secrets
to financial success plus receive Tony's
powerful audio tape Tony Robbins program
offers you the easiest most affordable
way to receive your Visa card with
fourteen point nine percent interest no
deposit required and guaranteed
acceptance or your money back
call this number now to take advantage
of this exciting new offer fact number
four he did a cameo role as himself in
the film shallow house tour in Jack
Black hey it's you you're the TV guru
guy yes Tony Robbins please the beaches
yeah I was interesting the Farrelly
Brothers are our friends and fans and
they're brilliant funny crazy guys and
they invited me to participate in the
movie and I didn't turn them out I just
said no because it wasn't for me and
when they brought me the script I was
moved by it because the message is about
inner beauty and not being a surface
driven person who's a part of my life's
about a hypothetical situation which do
you prefer the girlfriend missing one
breasts or half a brain
ooh Tuffy and then I found out that the
story was written by a man who'd bought
my personal power audio program off of
television off an infomercial years ago
so I said yeah I want to do this yeah I
wasn't originally in the script
they were using this like seance guy to
do this you got a pattern of looking
women and judging them by the exterior
you know they wrote the script and you
know none of it was really me and I said
you know I've memorized this and I'm
very respectful you put me in the middle
of this movie as a central character and
but this is not what I'd say so I'll do
what you want but can I just show you
what I'd really do and they go Tony it's
a movie I said just you know let me try
one specific time we're really shallow
that he'll seem right smack I'm on hand
here that was coming they had no idea
the coming in fact they laughed so hard
when it happened that his reactions are
not fake reactions that are active
reactions they were real reactions you
know what's coming and then that they
shot the thing 15 angles cuz everybody's
laughing so our cameras were shaking
everything else but you know that's why
I approached my approaches jar people
until we help me quickly not talk about
things it was a great privilege to be
part of the film and I have no desire to
be an actor but I'm grateful that I was
part of that great little story fact
number five u.s. President Bill Clinton
called him before he was impeached I get
a phone call where a child is suicidal
or President States calls and says
they're gonna peach me in the morning
what should I do that actually happened
she called you the night before 1998 and
said Tony they may be impeaching me in
the morning what should I do what an
extraordinary position of responsibility
you have not the only person he calls
you're one of the people he killed
yes just step back for a moment that
moment how did you feel me despite all
these incredible things you've
experienced to have the president of
your country call you in his great hour
of need well you know if you're thinking
about yourself at a moment like that you
can't really serve so you know the deal
about you what I felt was a sense of
responsibility and I also felt I need to
sell him straight or what I really
believed and you know I knew he's gonna
get different opinions and I don't
really talk about what I do is someone
less they speak about it but I did speak
at that point and said frankly you know
you're not going to be impeached in the
morning easy for me to say I'm not here
position it just politically it's not
gonna happen but what you have to decide
is what your legacy is gonna be what's
your outcome because you have to decide
what you're gonna be able to say that
people at home can tell their children
about you have to look at what you can
do legally but if I were you I'd be
doing what you know is right and nothing
less than that process because you want
to look yourself in the face fact number
six the best advice he ever got was also
from Jim Rohn what's the best piece of
advice you've ever done have had so much
but I think one of the most important
ones was early in my life one of my
mentors men named Jim Rohn said Tony all
you have to focus on your life is find a
way to add more value than anybody else
does and you'll never have to worry
about anything be the person that does
more for others and life will just be
any one thing you want out of it really
is what it is and so and he also said
the way to do that is every day work
harder than yourself anything else
because if you become more intelligent
more valuable more skilled you can add
more value to other people
fact number seven he wants to feed over
1 billion people over Thanksgiving you
were growing up you were really poor
right extremely in the poor we had no
money for Thanksgiving for food it's
part of why last year I fed I started
out feeding when I was 17 I started
feeding family since dad was 11 and I've
had two families literally and it was so
moving I said I'm gonna double I went to
four and then eight and then it was a
like a game to see how could I reach
more people and then I started with some
my employees and then eventually got two
million people here than two million
then I started matching my foundation
with two million so for 12 years I've
fed four million people a year and then
when I was writing this book I'm
interviewing if you can imagine all
these people start with nothing in our
multi-billionaires at the same time
Congress cut food stamps called snap now
but it was food stamps originally by
eight billion dollars so it's equivalent
to give you an idea of every family
that's being supported giving up all
their meals one week out of every month
for 12 months so I decided I wanted to
do something about it so I got a five
million dollar advance of the book I
gave all the money to feeding America
and then I said if I want to feed 100
million people what I got to do so I
wrote a much bigger check and now I'm so
it we did a hundred two million people
last year but now I'm gonna do a hundred
million again this year and I got a plan
to feed a billion people over the next
10 years so I'm it's it's so full circle
from where I began it's crazy and it's
it's it's an incredible privilege to be
I'll make a difference like that
fact number 8 he uses cryotherapy to
help his body recover from being onstage
all day I'm like an athlete you got a
train your nervous system
besides physically working out I also
trained my mind to do in my emotions to
do what's the most difficult and I do
that all kinds of ways I like to play at
my edge you know that's how you get
better so I put my demands myself but
the first thing I do every morning is
part of that ritual is I jump into
Jacuzzi which loosen the muscles and
then I jump in freezing cold water I
have a cold plunge if he would it's 57
degrees and I hop into that thing I also
for recovery sake I use cryotherapy
which was developed in Europe it's
amazing a lot of athletes around the
world are using it now and it lowers
your body temperature using nitrogen so
if there's no water on your you would
freeze it up or you would burn by using
these gases it brings the temperature
down your body down to minus 225
Fahrenheit which is my wild for three
minutes and what it does is it like
resets your whole nervous system and it
takes all the inflammation out of your
body so I'm on stage and I'll do 27
miles on my most intense day of a
three-day program so I'm doing like
multiple days of ultramarathon because
I'm not standing there talking I mean
people would not come if B won't sit for
a three hour movie someone spent 300
million dollars on to make for two hours
they're gonna stay with me for 50 hours
over weekend I gotta deliver right and I
got you know the Paul Tudor Jones is the
world in there the Oprah Winfrey's in
you know Oprah tells me Tony I love you
but I can't sit anywhere for more than
two hours in the end of 12 hours you
stand your chair going on camera this is
one the greatest experience of my life
well to do that you're standing still
I'm plunging the audience I'm doing
things I'm spontaneous so that's a lot
of miles so I'm literally doing one
marathon I go into this machine and
three minutes later I come out the next
day it's like instead of all these aches
and pains and tears I'm recovered so I'm
always looking for technology that can
enhance my ability to perform and
produce great results and also stay
healthy in fact number nine he has one
of the three most popular TED talk
videos of all time for his talk why we
do what we do
I have to tell you I'm both challenged
and excited my excitement is I get a
chance to give something back my
challenge is the shortest seminar I
usually do is 50 hours I'm not
exaggerating I do weekend's and what I
do right even more than that obviously
coach people but I'm into immersion
because how'd you learn language you
didn't learn it by just learning
principles you've got in it and you did
it so often that it became real and the
bottom line of why I'm here besides
being crazy mofo is that I'm really in a
position I'm not here to motivate you
obviously you don't need that a lot of
times that's what people think I do and
it's the furthest thing from it what
happens though is people say to me oh I
don't need any motivation and I said
well that's interesting that's not what
I do I'm the white guy I don't know why
you do what you do what is your motive
for action what is it that Drive you in
your life today not 10 years ago are you
running the same pattern because I
believe that the invisible force of
internal Drive activate is the most
important thing in the world I'm here
because I believe emotion is the force
of life all of us here have great minds
you know most of us here great minds hey
I don't know if I know the category but
we all know how to think and with our
minds we can rationalize anything we can
make anything happen
we can I agree with what was described a
few days ago but this idea that people
work in their self-interest but we all
know that that's [ __ ] at times you
don't work in your self-interest all the
time because when emotion comes into it
the wiring changes in the way it
functions and so it's wonderful for us
to think intellectually about how the
life of the world is and especially
those who are very smart we can play
this game in our head but I really want
to know what's driving you and what I'd
like to maybe invite you to do by the
end of this talk is explore where you
are today for two reasons one so that
you can contribute more and two so that
hopefully we can not just understand
other people more but maybe appreciate
them more and create the kinds of
connections that can stop some of the
challenges that we face in our society
today they're only going to get
magnified by the very technology that's
connecting us because it's making us
intersect and that intersection doesn't
always create the view of everybody now
understands everybody and everybody
appreciates everybody so I've had an
obsession basically for 30 years and
that obsession has been what makes the
difference in the quality of people's
lives
what makes the difference in their
performance because that's what I got
hired to do I got to produce the result
now that's what I've done for 30 years I
get the phone call when the athlete is
burning down on national television and
they were ahead by five strokes and now
they can't get back on the course and I
got to do something right now I get the
result in nothing matters I get the
phone call when the child is going to
commit suicide and I go to something
right now and in 29 years I'm very
grateful to tell you I've never lost one
in 29 years it doesn't mean I won't
someday but I've done it and the reason
is an understanding of these human needs
I want to talk to you about so when I
get those calls about performance that's
one thing like how do you make a change
but also I'm looking to see what is it
that's shaping that person's ability to
contribute to do something beyond
themselves so maybe the real question is
you know I look at life and say there's
two master lessons one is there's the
science of achievement which almost
everything this room is mastered to an
amazing step that's how do you take the
invisible and make it visible right how
you take what you're dreaming out and
make it happen whether it be your
business your contribution society money
whatever it is for you your body your
family but the other lesson of life that
is rarely mastered is the art of
fulfillment because science is easy
right we know the rules you write the
code you follow the and you get the
result once you know the game you just
you know you up the ante don't you but
when it comes to fulfillment that's an
art and the reason is it's about
appreciation and it's about contribution
you can only feel so much by yourself so
I've had an interesting laboratory try
to answer the question of the real
question which is what's the difference
in somebody's life if you look at
somebody like those people that you've
given everything to like that all the
resources they say they need you give
them not one hundred older computer you
give them the best computer you give
them love you gave them joy you were
there to comfort them
and those people very often and you know
some of them I'm sure end up the rest of
their life with all those love education
money a background spending the life
going in and out of rehab and then you
meet people they've been through
ultimate pain psychologically sexually
spiritually emotionally abused and not
always but often they become some of the
people to contribute the most to society
so the course we gotta ask ourselves
really is what is it what is it the
shapes us and we live in a therapy
culture most of us don't do that but the
cultures of therapy culture what I mean
by that is the mindset that we are past
and everybody in this room you wouldn't
be in this room if you bought that
theory but the most of society thinks
biography
destiny the past equals the future and
of course it does if you live there but
what people in this room know and what
we have to remind ourselves though
because you can know something
intellectually you can know what to do
and then not use it not apply it so
really we're gonna my selves is decision
is the ultimate power that's what it
really is now when you ask people you
know have you failed to achieve
something how many have ever failed to
achieve something significant your life
say I
thanks for the interaction on a high
level there but if you if you ask people
why didn't you achieve something
somebody was working for you you know or
a part nor even yourself and you failed
to achieve a goal what's the reason
people say they fail to achieve what do
they tell you don't have didn't know
enough didn't have the knowledge didn't
have the money didn't have the time
didn't have the technology you know I
didn't have the right manager didn't
have the Supreme Court
[Applause]
[Music]
and
what all those including the Supreme
Court have in common
they are a claim to you missing
resources and they may be accurate you
may not have the money you may not have
the Supreme Court but that is not the
defining factor
and you correct me if I'm wrong the
defining factor is never resources its
resourcefulness and what I mean
specifically rather than just some
phrase is if you have emotion human
emotion something that I experienced
from you
day before yesterday at a level that is
as profound as I've ever experienced and
if you communicate with that emotion I
believe you would have beat his ass and
won
but how easy for me to tell him what he
should do
[Music]
idiot Robbins but I know when we watch
the debates when we watch the debate at
that time there were emotions that
blocked people's ability to get this
man's intellect and capacity and the way
they came across to some people in that
day because I know people that wanted to
vote in your direction and didn't and
I'm loves upset but there was emotion
that was there how many know what I'm
talking about here say I so emotion is
in if we get the right emotion we can
get ourselves to do anything we can get
through it if you're creative enough
playful enough fun enough can you get
through to anybody yes or no if you
don't have the money but you're creative
to determine if you find the way so this
is the ultimate resource but this is not
the story that people tell us right the
story people tell us as a bunch of
different stories they tell us we don't
the resources but ultimately if you take
a look here flip it up if you would they
say what all the reason they haven't
Conway said that next one please
he's broken my pattern that son of a
but I appreciated the energy I'll tell
you that
what determines your resources we've
said decision shape destiny which is my
focus here if decisions shape destiny
what determines it is three decisions
what are you gonna focus on right now
you have to decide what you're gonna
focus on in this second consciously or
unconsciously the mini you decide to
focus on something got to give it a
meaning and whatever that meaning is
produces emotion is this the end or the
beginning it's God punishing me or
rewarding me or is this the roll of the
dice in emotion then creates what we're
going to do or the action so think about
your own life the decisions that have
shaped your destiny and that sounds
really heavy but in the last five or ten
years fifteen years have there been some
decisions you've made that you made a
different decision your life would be
completely different
how many can think of honestly better or
worse say I so the bottom line is maybe
it was where to go to work and you met
the love of your life there maybe was a
career decision I know that Google
geniuses I saw here I mean I understand
that their decision was to sell their
technology at first what do they made
that decision versus to build their own
culture how would the world be different
how will their lives be different their
impact the history of our world is these
decisions when a woman stands up and
says no I won't go to the back of the
bus she didn't just affect her life that
decision shaped our culture or someone
standing in front of a tank or being in
a position like our Lance Armstrong and
someone says to you you got testicular
cancer that's pretty tough for any male
especially if you ride a bike
you got in your brain you got in your
lungs but what was his decision of what
to focus on different the most people
what did it mean it wasn't the end it
was the beginning what I'm gonna do
he goes off and wins seven championships
he never once once before the cancer
because he got emotional fitness
psychological strength that's the
difference in human beings that I've
seen of the three million I've been
around cause that's what my lab I've had
three million people from eighty
different countries that I've had a
chance to interact with over the last
twenty nine years and after a while
patterns become obvious you see that
South America and Africa maybe connect
in a certain way right other people say
all that sounds ridiculous it's simple
so what shaped Lance what shapes you to
invisible forces very quickly one state
we all have had time say if you're the
time you did something and after you did
you thought to yourself I can't believe
I said that I can't believe I did that
that was so stupid who's been there say
I have you done something after you do
you that was me right it wasn't your
ability was your state you're a model of
the world is what shapes you long term
your model the world is the filter
that's what's shaping us that's what
makes people make decisions we want to
influence somebody we don't know what
already influences them and it's made
about three parts I believe first what's
your target what are you after
which I believe it's not your desires
you need your desires of goals how many
ever got a goal desire and thought is
this all there is how many been there
say I so its needs we have I believe
there are six human needs second once
you know what the target that's driving
you is and then you uncover it for the
truth you don't form it you uncover it
then you find out what's your map what's
the belief systems that are telling you
how to get those needs some people think
a way to get those needs is destroy the
world some people is to build something
create something love someone and then
there's the fuel you pick so very
quickly
six needs let me tell you what there are
first one certainty now these are not
goals or desires either universal
everyone needs certainty that they can
avoid pain at least be comfortable now
how do you get it control everybody
develop a skill give up smoke a
cigarette if you got totally certain
ironically even though we all need that
like you're not certain about your
health or your children or money you
don't think about much where you're not
sure the ceilings gonna hold up here
listen any speaker but while we go for
certainly differently if we get total
certainty we get what do you feel if
you're certain you know what's gonna
and when that's gonna happen how it's
gonna happen what would you feel bored
out of your mind so God in her infinite
wisdom gave us a second human need which
is uncertainty we need variety we need
surprise how many of you here love
surprises say aye
[ __ ] you like the surprises you want
the ones you don't want you call
problems but you need them so variety is
important have you ever rented a video
or a film that you've already seen was
done this get a [ __ ] life why are you
doing it you're certain it's good cuz
you read it before I saw it before but
you're hoping it's been long enough
you've forgotten up this variety third
human need critical significance we all
need to feel important special unique
you can get it by making more money you
can do it by being more spiritual you
can do it by getting yourself in a
situation will you put more tattoos and
earrings in place as humans don't want
to know whatever it takes the fastest
way to do this if you have no background
no culture and no belief and resources
or resourcefulness is violence if I put
a gun to your head and I live in the
hood instantly I'm significant zero to
ten how I ten how certain in mind you're
gonna respond to me ten how much
uncertainty who knows what's gonna
happen next kind of exciting like climb
it up into a cave and doing that stuff
all the way down there total variety and
uncertainty and it's significant isn't
it so you want to risk your life for it
so that's why violence has always been
around will be around us we have a
consciousness change as a species now
you can get significance a million ways
but to be significant you got to be
unique and different here's what we
really need connection alot fourth need
we all want it most people settle for
connection just loves to scary don't
want to get hurt who here has ever been
hurt in an intimate relationship say I
if you don't raise your hand you'll have
that other [ __ ] to come on and you're
gonna get hurt again aren't you glad you
came to this positive visit but here's
what's true we need it we can do it
through intimacy through friendship
through prayer through walking in nature
if nothing else works for you get a dog
don't get a cat get a dog as if you
leave for two minutes it's like you've
been gone for six months when you shut
back up again five minutes later right
now these first four needs every human
finds a way to meet even if you lie to
yourself units of split personalities
but the last two needs the first four
needs are called the needs of the
personality is what I call it the last
two are the needs of the Spirit
and this is where fulfillment comes you
won't get fulfillment for the first four
you'll figure away smoke drink do
whatever meet the first for it but the
last to number five you must glow we all
know the answer here if you don't grow
you what the relationships not growing
if a business is not growing if you're
not growing doesn't how much money you
have how many friends you have how many
people love you you feel like hell and
the reason we grow I believe is so we
have something to give a value because
the six need is to contribute beyond
ourselves because we all know corny as
it sounds
the secret of living is giving we all
know life's not about me it's about we
this culture knows that this room knows
that it's exciting when you see Nicholas
if you're talking about his hundred
dollar computer the most passionate
exciting thing is here's a genius but
he's got a calling now you can feel the
difference in him and is beautiful and
that calling can touch other people in
my own life my life was touched because
when I was 11 years old
Thanksgiving no money no food and we're
not gonna starve but my father was
totally messed up my mom was letting him
know how bad he messed up and somebody
came to the door and delivered food my
father made three decisions I know what
they were briefly his focus was this is
charity what does it mean I'm worthless
what I got to do leave my family which
he did the time when the most painful
experiences of life my three decisions
gave me a different path I said focus on
there's food with a concept yeah second
but this is what changed my life this is
what shaped me as a human being
somebody's gift I don't know who it is I
thought my father always said no one
gives a [ __ ] and all sudden somebody I
don't know they're not asking for this
giving our family food looking out for
us it made me believe this what does it
mean that strangers care and what that
made me decide if strangers care about
me and my family I care about them what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna I'm gonna do
something make a difference so when I
was seventeen I went out one day and
Thanksgiving it was my target for years
have enough money feed two families most
fun thing I ever did in my life most
moving then next year I did four and I
didn't tell anybody was doing next year
eight I wasn't doing four brownie points
but after eight I thought I could use
some help so sure enough I went out and
what did i do I got my friends involved
in I grew companies in the eleven
companies and I built the foundation now
18 years later I'm proud to tell you
last year we fed 2 million people in 35
countries through our foundation all
during the holidays Thanksgiving
Christmas and all
thank you so I don't tell you how to
brag I tell you guys I'm proud of human
beings because they get excited to
contribute once they've had the chance
to experience it not talked about
so finally I'm about out of time it's a
the target that shapes you here's what's
different about people we have the same
needs but are you a certainty freak is
that what you value most or uncertainty
this man here couldn't be a certainty
freak if he climbed those through those
caves are you driven by significance or
love we all need all six but whatever
your lead system is tilts you in a
different direction and as you move in a
direction you have a destination or
destiny the second piece is the map
think of that as the operating system
tells you how to get there and some
people's map is I'm gonna save lives
even if I die for other people and
they're firemen somebody else is I'm
gonna kill people to do it they're
trying to meet the same needs of
significance right they want to honor
God or honor their family but they have
a different map and there are seven
different beliefs I can't go through
them because I'm done the last piece is
emotion I said one of the parts of the
map was like time some people's idea of
a long time is 100 years somebody else
says is 3 seconds which is what I have
and the last one I've already mentioned
that felt you if you got a target and
you got a map and let's say I can't use
Google because I love maps and they
haven't made it good format yet so if
you use MapQuest how many made this
fatal mistake of using that press that
sometimes you use this thing and you
don't get there well imagine if your
beliefs guarantee you can never get to
where you want to go the last thing is
emotion now here's what I'll tell you
about emotion there are 6,000 emotions
that we all have words for in the
English language was just a linguistic
representation right it changes my
language but if your dominant emotions
if I have more time I have 20,000 people
or a thousand and I am write down all
the emotions that they experience in an
average week and I give as long as they
need and on one side there are
empowering emotions the others
disempowering guess how many emotions
people experience less than 12 and half
of those make them feel like [ __ ] so
they got five or six good freaking
feelings right it's like they feel happy
happy excited oh [ __ ]
frustrated frustrated overwhelmed
depressed how many of you know somebody
who no matter what happens finds a way
to get pissed off how he knows the Mayo
test
or Nemo what happens no matter what
happens they find a way to be happier
excited how many Elsa male I guess come
on when 9/11 happened I'll finish with
this I was in Hawaii I was with two
thousand people from 45 countries we
were translating four languages
simultaneously for a program that I was
conducting for a week the night before
was called emotional mastery I got up
had no plan for this and I said we had
Alyssa fireworks I do crazy fun stuff
and then at the end of thought I had
this plan I was gonna say but I never do
what I'm gonna say and all of a sudden I
said when do people really start to live
when they face death and then with this
whole thing about if you were gonna get
off this island
if nine days from now you were gonna die
who would you call what would you say
what did you do one woman well that
night is when I want to happen one woman
had come to the seminar and what she
came there she or her previous boyfriend
had been kidnapped and murdered her
friend or a new boyfriend wanted to
marry her and she said no he said if you
leave and go to Hawaii thing it's over
with us she said it's over when I
finished that night she called him and
left a message true story at the top of
the World Trade Center where he worked
saying honey I love you I just want you
to know I I want to marry it was stupid
of me she was asleep because it was 3:00
a.m. for us when he called her back from
the top and said honey I can't tell you
what this means he said I don't have to
tell you this but you give me the
greatest gift because I'm gonna die
and she played the recording for us in
the room she was on Larry King later and
he said you're probably wondering how on
earth this could happen you twice and he
said all I can say to you is this must
be God's message to you honey from now
on every day give your all love you all
don't let anything ever stop you she
finishes and a man stands up and he says
I'm from Pakistan I'm a Muslim I'd love
to hold your hand and say I'm sorry but
frankly this is retribution I can't tell
you the rest cos I'm out of time
[Applause]
oh shoot
[Applause]
ten seconds
[Applause]
10 seconds I want to be respectful 10
seconds all I can tell you as I brought
this man on stage with a man from New
York who worked in the World Trade
Center because I had about 200 New
Yorkers there more than 50 lost their
entire companies their friends marking
off their Palm Pilots one financial
trader this woman made of steel bawling
30 friends crossing off it all died and
what I did the people said what are we
gonna focus on what does this mean was
it what are we gonna do and I took the
group and got people to focus on if you
didn't lose somebody today your focus
could be how to serve somebody else
there are people don't want my god I'm
just so angry and screaming yelling that
actually wasn't for New York she's not
an American she doesn't know anybody
here I said you always get angry she
said yes guilty people got guilty sad
people got sad and I took these two men
and did what I call an indirect
negotiation Jewish man was family in the
occupied territories some New York who
would have died if he was at work that
day and his man who want to be a
terrorist and made it very clear in the
integration that happened is on a film
which I'll be happy to send you so you
can really see what actually happened
said of my verbalization of it but the
two of them not only came together and
change their beliefs and models of the
world but they worked together to bring
for almost four years now to various
mosques and synagogues the idea of how
to create peace and you wrote a book
which is called my jihad my way of peace
so transformation can happen so my
invitation to use this explore your web
the web in here the needs the beliefs
the emotions that are controlling you
for two reasons so there's more of you
to give me achieve - we don't want to do
it but I mean give cuz that's what's
gonna fill you out and secondly so you
can appreciate not just understand
that's intellectual that's mine but
appreciate what's driving other people
it's the only way our world is gonna
change god bless you thank you hope
there's a service
so thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed this is a test new
series for us curious what you think
about it should that did you know series
continue is there someone you'd like us
to profile in the next did you know
series let us know did you hate this
series and never want to see it again
leaving the comments below
we're gonna use your feedback to make
some decisions I also wanna give a quick
chatter to Jennifer Clark Jennifer thank
you so much for picking a copy off of my
book your one word it really really
really really means a lot to me so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much loved and I'll see you soon